>> Greg: I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT EXACTLY WHAT
HE WANTED.
I WROTE DOWN, DRINKING OUT OF
TOILETS, THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN,
INCLUDING -- COLLUDING WITH
RUSSIANS.
I THINK WE FOUND THE ANSWER TO
THAT.
MOST CORRUPT PRESIDENCY IN
HISTORY?
MILLIONS DIED DUE TO TRUMP?
BECAUSE OF HEALTH CARE?
A FEW OTHER THINGS.
>> Dana: THE THING THAT I
PICKED UP ON INITIALLY, THE
FIRST SPEAKER, PRESSLEY, SHE
REFUSED TO REFER TO DONALD TRUMP
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BUT ONLY AS THE
OCCUPANT OF THE OFFICE.
THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE A
COMPROMISE HERE.
>> Greg: IT IS VERY ANTIFA.
>> Jesse: DONALD TRUMP WON
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE.
NANCY AND THE SQUAD LOST.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY WANT TO
VICTIMIZE THEMSELVES EVEN
FURTHER.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE WAY TO
GO AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU HAVE TO MEET THEM ON THE
SAME LEVEL.
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO PLAY THE
VICTIM AND POUT AND NOW THEY
WANT TO IMPEACH HIM FOR
TWEETING.
THEY ARE SAYING HE'S A WHITE
NATIONALIST AND HE'S COMMITTING
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND
DEPORTING ALL THESE PEOPLE.
OBAMA ACTUALLY DEPORTED MORE AND
ALSO PUT PEOPLE IN CAGES.
THE POINT OF THIS IS THIS: AOC
LIKES TO TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH SHE
LOVES THIS COUNTRY AND THEY ARE
ALL SAYING HOW MUCH THEY LOVE
THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU WANT TO BANKRUPT THIS
COUNTRY, IF YOU WANT TO OPEN UP
ALL THE BORDERS, IF YOU WANT TO
DESTROY THE MILITARY, DESTROY
CAPITALISM AND FOCUS ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS MORE THAN AMERICAN
CITIZENS, THEN I THINK I HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION OF LOVE THAN
SHE DOES.
>> Greg: I WANT TO KNOW THAT
DEFINITION.
WE'LL TALK LATER.
>> Capri: HANO I FOLLOW THAT,
JESSE WATTERS?
>> Capri: AS THE DEMOCRAT
HERE, I FEEL FOR THEM.
I KNOW THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT A NUMBER OF
THINGS THEY SAID AND THEY
BROUGHT UP SOME POLICY AREAS
THAT I THINK COULD ACTUALLY HAVE
LEGITIMATE DIALOGUE AROUND.
THAT BEING SAID, THEY TRIED BUT
I THINK THEY FAILED TO SAY
THERE'S AN THEME OF THIS IS A
DISTRACTION.
THE TWEETS ARE A DISTRACTION AT
THE SAME TIME THEY CIRCLE BACK.
THEY CIRCLE BACK TO IMPEACHMENT
AND RACISM IN ALL THESE OTHER
ISSUES AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE MINUTIA
OF THEIR WORDS IN THE OCCUPANT
OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
IF THEY REALLY DON'T WANT TO BE
A DISTRACTION, NUMBER ONE, TO
HOLD THE PRESS CONFERENCE AND
NEVER TO COME ACTUALLY DO THE
WORK OF THE PEOPLE, I SAY THAT
FOR EVERYBODY -- DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, INDEPENDENT -- IF
YOU ARE FAIR AND ELECTED TO DO
YOUR JOB, DO IT.
DON'T PLAY GAMES.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO BE A
DISTRACTION, MEAN IT.
>> Dan: THE OCCUPANT LINE WAS
A COMPLETE AND UTTER DISGRACE.
YOU CAN'T ON ONE HAND SAY THIS
IS HORRIBLE.
THE PRESIDENT ASKS FOUR DULY
ELECTED NUMBERS OF CONGRESS TO
FIX THE COUNTRY AND THEN TURN
AROUND AND SAY HE'S ILLEGITIMATE
BECAUSE HE'S AN OCCUPANT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
PROBABLY AMONGST 10% OF THE
ELECTORATE, YOU SCORED HUGE.
OTHER THAN THAT, YOU ENTIRELY
GLUE IT.
SECONDLY --
THEY SAID THE SQUAD IS POWERFUL.
NO, IT'S NOT.
YOU GOT ZERO VOTES ON THE GREEN
NEW DEAL.
THE ONLY FOUR TO VOTE AGAINST
THE AID PACKAGE OF THE BORDER.
I RAN FOR CONGRESS AND LOST AND
ONLY GOT 15,000 LESS VOTES THAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
SHE'S NOT AS POWERFUL AS THEY
THINK.
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE I THINK
DID THEM ABSOLUTELY NO FAVORS.
I THINK TRUMP COMES OUT OF THAT
AN ENORMOUS WINTER.
OCCUPANT OF THE WHITE HOUSE IS
DISGRACEFUL.
>> Dana: CAN WE MENTION THE
PROFANITY?
OR NO?
>> Greg: I GUESS.
THEY CAN ARGUE THAT THAT'S WHAT
TRUMP SAID SO I'M GOING TO SAY
IT.
>> Dana: HE DIDN'T SAY IT ON
LIVE TELEVISION AT 5:00 IN THE
AFTERNOON.
THEY ARE QUOTING FROM OTHER
PLACES.
HE DIDN'T SAY ON TELEVISION.
>> Greg: THIS IS COMING FOR
THE ONLY PERSON ON "THE FIVE"
WHOEVER SWORE ON OUR SHOW.
THE MAN WITH THE ALLIGATOR.
HERE IS THE LATEST TWEET.
"THE DEMS WERE TRYING TO
DISTANCE THEMSELVES FROM THE
PROGRESSIVES BUT THEY ARE FORCED
TO EMBRACE THEM.
THAT MEANS THEY ARE ENDORSING
SOCIALISM, HATE OF ISRAEL, AND
THE USA!
NOT GOOD FOR THE DEMOCRATS!"
WAS THAT THE PLAN?
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S THE PLAN BUT IT'S THE
RESULTS.
HE'S GOTTEN THE DEMOCRATS TO
CIRCLE THE WAGON AROUND THESE
FOUR PROGRESSIVES.
THEY ARE GOING TO FUND RAISE
THROUGH THE ROOF.
I DON'T KNOW THIS FOR SURE.
THEY ARE ENJOYING THIS MOMENT IN
THE SPOTLIGHT.
THEY'RE GOING TO RAISE THEIR
PROFILE BIG TIME.
THEY'RE GOING TO RUN INTO A
STRONG HEAD WIND WITH NANCY.
HE'S NOT GOING TO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS ANYMORE.
TO YOUR POINT EARLIER, IF THIS
COUNTRY WAS REALLY DOING BADLY
AND WE WERE IN A RECESSION AND
THIS WAS THE 70s AND THEIR
RELIANCE ON THE BLOCK FOR
GASOLINE AND WE WERE AT WAR
AND WE ARE AT EACH OTHER'S
THROATS OF THE STREETS, THAT
WOULD BE ONE THING FOR THEM TO
CALL FOR THIS IMPEACHMENT OF
THIS HORRIBLE CRIMINAL.
BUT THIS COUNTRY IS BOOMING
RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE THE LOWEST BLACK AND
HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE ARE AT PEACE.
EVERYONE IS FOCUSED ON NETFLIX
TAKING OUT "FRIENDS" AND "THE
OFFICE."
THINGS ARE SO GOOD WE ARE
WORRYING ABOUT A TWEET.
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD ONLY TAKE
OUT A FEW SEASONS OF "THE
OFFICE."
>> Jesse: THE OLDER ONES
WITHOUT MICHAEL SCOTT.
>> Dana: THEY ARE THE FOUR
PROGRESSIVE HORSEMEN OF THE
APOCALYPSE FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
25 YEARS FROM NOW, THIS MIGHT BE
WHERE AMERICA IS.
HOPEFULLY NOT.
THAT'S NOT WHERE AMERICA IS
RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD IMAGINE THEY MIGHT
THUNDERING OFF IT BUT THE
PRESIDENT AND THE RNC IS ABOUT
TO ANNOUNCE THEY RAISED
$108 MILLION IN THE SECOND
QUARTER OF THE YEAR.
MONEY IS NOT GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM FOR THE REPUBLICANS IN
THIS REELECTION EFFORT AND MAYBE
NOT FOR THE DEMOCRATS EITHER BUT
MONEY IS NOT GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM.
>> Greg: LET'S THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE BIG STORY WAS COMING
INTO THE WEEKEND, THE I.C.E.
RAIDS.
WHAT HAPPENED?
WHERE DID THAT GO?
>> Capri: NOTHING HAPPENED.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT I'M
SAYING.
WERE NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: AND WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS OR
ELIZABETH WARREN.
THEY'VE MOVE THESE FRONTRUNNERS
COMPLETELY OFF THE FRONT PAGE.
BIDEN HAD AN ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT
HIS NEW HEALTH CARE PLAN TODAY.
THAT'S GOING NOWHERE.
>> Dana: SAYING THAT IF YOU
LIKE YOUR HEALTH CARE, YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR HEALTH CARE.
>> Jesse: IS ONLY ONE DEMOCRAT
IS JUST >> Dan: WHAT HE SAYS
-- IT'S ENTIRELY INGENUOUS.
ILHAN OMAR HAS SPENT TIME TAKING
SHOTS AT PEOPLE AND THEN IN THE
PRESS CONFERENCE COMES OUT AND
THE TALK WAS LOVELY AND TALKING
IN THESE FLOWER RETURNS BUT
THAT'S NOT HOW SHE IS ON
TWITTER.
ANTI-SEMITIC TROPES, NOT LIVING
OUR VALUES IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT DOESN'T APPEAL TO PEOPLE IN
AMERICA WHO LOVE IT.
NOBODY WANTS TO HEAR ABOUT HOW
YOUR COUNTRY IS CRAP ALL THE
TIME.
>> Capri: I DON'T AGREE WITH
OF OMAR'S COMMENTS ON ISRAEL AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE BUT YOU
HAVE TO ADMIT THOSE WOMEN
STANDING ON THAT STAGE,
DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT KIND OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE UNITED STATES
THAN MANY OF THEIR COLLEAGUES.
IT DOESN'T MAKE IT RIGHT OR
WRONG.
IT MAKES IT DIFFERENT.
THAT DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE
INFORMS HOW THEY COME ABOUT --
>> Dan: AOC, I KNOW THE AREA
SHE GREW UP IN.
SHE MENTIONED THE BRONX.
SHE'S THE CONGRESSMAN FOR
JACKSON HEIGHTS.
MY GRANDPARENTS FROM AN
IMMIGRANT FAMILY FROM ITALY.
THEY OWNED A STORE IN HARLEM.
AOC IS A SITTING UNITED STATES
CONGRESSWOMAN.
REGARDLESS --
SHE'S AN AMERICAN SUCCESS STORY.
ILHAN OMAR, EVEN MORE PROFOUND
SUCCESS STORY.
THE STORY COMING FROM THEM THAT
AMERICA IS AN AWFUL PLACE, THERE
IS A COGNITIVE DISSONANCE THERE.
ARE YOU NOT GETTING AT?
YOU ARE IN CONGRESS.
YEAR OF POWER AND MONEY AND
INFLUENCE.
YOU CANNOT DO THIS ANYWHERE ELSE
IN THE WORLD.
>> Capri: THEY ARE TRYING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT IN THE WAY
THEY THINK IS BEST.
AGAIN, I'M NOT SAYING IT'S RIGH
RIGHT.
>> Dan: BUT AMERICA SOX IS NOT
A MESSAGE.
I'M SORRY.
>> Jesse: OMAR SAYS SHE HAS
THIS GREAT YEAR FOR RACISM.
SHE CAN HEAR IT AND READ BETWEEN
THE LINES AND THAT
ANTI-SEMITISM?
CAN'T HEAR A THING.
THAT'S WHERE I THINK SHE'S BEING
DISINGENUOUS.
SHE PICKED UP EVERY LITTLE THING
IN BETWEEN THE LINES OF ITS
RACIST.
IF IT'S NOT RACIST.
BUT SHE SAYS IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
BENJAMINS.
WAD?
>> Dana: A WRITTEN -- COLUMN
IN "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"?
GOES INTO THE HISTORY AND
BACKGROUND IN PARTICULAR FOR
OMAR AND HOW IT TAKES A
DIFFERENT OUTLOOK OF HOW SHE WAS
BROUGHT UP.
ESPECIALLY WHEN SHE WAS IN
SOMALIA.
>> Dan: SHE SAID SHE HAD TO
UNLEARN ANTI-SEMITISM,
DISCUSSING THINGS TAUGHT TO HER
AS A CHILD AND HOW SHE FEELS
SOME PEOPLE HAVE NEVER LEARNED
IT.
BASED ON SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
USED IN THESE AWFUL TWEETS
SPEAKING ABOUT JEWISH PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD, IT'S GROSS.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CALL IT OUT.
>> Greg: I TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT IN A WAY THEY ARE IN A
PROTECTED CLASS WHERE THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO SAY THINGS.
OH, BUT THEY HAD A DIFFERENT
LIFE EXPERIENCE.
I CALLED THEM THE SNAIL GARTERS.
A SMALL, INSIGNIFICANT GROUP
EVERYONE PROTECTS.
>> Jesse: I CALL THEM THAT.
I READ YOUR MONOLOGUE.
THESE WOMEN ARE MINORITIES BEING
CRITICIZED BUT THEY ARE NOT
BEING CRITICIZED BECAUSE THEY
ARE MINORITIES.
IT'S A BIG DISTINCTION.
>> Dana: DO YOU KNOW WHO WROTE
THAT?
MAUREEN DOWD.
SHE SAID PEOPLE ARE NOT
DISAGREEING WITH YOU BECAUSE OF
YOUR COLOR.
THEY ARE DISAGREE WITH YOU
BECAUSE OF YOUR IDEAS.
>> Jesse: IF THESE WERE WHITE
GUYS FROM OHIO.
TRUMP WOULD BE RIPPING THEM AS
WELL.
>> Dan: EQUAL OPPORTUNITY GUY
WHEN IT COMES TO FILLING PEOPLE.
>> Capri: NONE OF WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY PRESIDENTIAL.